sir Alec Guinness was another actor who
had issues with the franchise now In
fairness when the first movie was being
made nobody really knew how much of a
big deal it would be so you have this
total Pro of the acting world who had
won awards and made a ton of Bank on
stage and on screen cut to him reading a
script with a dude in a black suit and
breathing machine chasing after a couple
other dudes and a furry creature yeah
the whole thing probably seemed a little
dubious in fact we know he thought that
because he wrote some letters to a buddy
during production calling the movie
quote fairy tale rubbish and the
dialogue pretty ropey dang Alex tell us
what you really think and yet he trudged
on why well he had a crush on the head
of the Wardrobe Department I'm kidding
it was his paycheck he made a hundred
and fifty thousand for the part way more
than everyone else but more importantly
he got two percent of whatever George
Lucas made from the box office Moolah so
he ended up pulling in about a hundred
million dollars money that still comes
to his estate even after his death